[Musica]
immaginiamo di essere in palestra
bene tuta scarpette da tennis sudore
fatica molti addominali perché andiamo
in palestra
magari per sviluppare una bella
tartaruga da mostrare in spiaggia oppure
per superare affrontare la fatidica
prova costume che ci affligge ogni anno
ma pensate se io vi dicessi di andare
nella palestra per la nostra mente quale
ambiente di figurate soprattutto esiste
una palestra per la mente e perché
dobbiamo allenare costantemente la
nostra mente bene la mia storia inizia
da qui la mia passione per lo studio del
cervello è nata circa tre anni fa quando
la professoressa di scienze mia
erroneamente inserito nella lista ai
partecipanti delle olimpiadi delle
neuroscienze e ancora oggi la ringrazio
per questo equivoco perché mi ha fatto
conoscere un nuovo mondo innanzitutto le
olimpiadi rete conoscenze sono una
competizione giovanile incentrata
proprio sullo studio di questi argomenti
è articolata in quattro fasi la prima a
cui tutti possono accedere si basa
appunto sulla preparazione degli
studenti negli argomenti più comuni
delle neuroscienze e i primi cinque che
si sfidano in prove di di neuroanatomia
di diagnosi di pazienti di prove vero
falso possono quindi accedere alla fase
successiva che a quella regionale nella
fase regionale le prove quindi crescono
di livello ed intensità e premiano i
migliori tre studenti che potranno
rappresentare la loro regione alla fase
finale della nazione quindi la nazionale
delle neuroscienze
qui 54
i migliori studenti da tutte le nazioni
d'italia possono sfidarsi in un rush
finale e si potrà quindi proclamare il
campione nazionale delle neuroscienze
che potrà quindi accedere all
international brain bee il comune della
competizione quest'anno ho avuto l'onore
e il piacere di rappresentare il mio
paese all'international brain bee
tenutosi a copenaghen in occasione del
france un forum di neuro scienziati che
appunto appunto lo scopo di promuovere
quelle idee che quelle idee più
innovative dei giovani ricercatori in
questo campo la cosa strabiliante è
stata appunto la mia preparazione
ho avuto modo di scoprire queste piccole
cellule che conoscevo solamente in
teoria i neuroni che da soli non possono
nulla in confronto al in confronto a
quello che possono fare come un gruppo
possono formare e far funzionare il
cervello e permettere che pensi che
memorizzi che ragioni tutte queste
funzioni possono essere svolte solamente
con l'integrazione di tutti queste
cellule che sono i neuroni dal senso ho
capito come la scienza si basa su queste
appunto piccole idee di questi giovani
ricercatori che solamente se integrate
assieme possono permettere grandi
scoperte scientifiche che favoriscono il
progresso umano ma per capire il motivo
per cui dobbiamo tenere costantemente
all allenamento la nostra mente è
fondamentale sapere che il nostro
cervello appunto è formato da queste
piccole cellule
i neuroni ne sono quasi 100 miliardi
cellule che devono appunto trasmettere
le informazioni prendere da cinque sensi
elaborarle e trasmettere ai suoi co
simili per l'appunto formare queste
facoltà che sono proprio solamente alla
mente umana per svolgere un compito
quindi così complesso queste cellule
hanno perso la capacità di riprodursi e
per questo motivo
perdiamo costantemente i neuroni sin
dalla nostra nascita quindi possiamo
paragonare il nostro cervello è come se
fosse una scheda madre che collega
tramite reti terminali a arredi
periferiche a sistemi periferiche questi
sistemi devono appunto portare
informazioni alla scheda madre
informazioni diverse l'una dalle altre
queste informazioni quindi non possono
confonderci ad esempio noi
state ascoltando me quindi lo stimolo
acustico non è confuso con lo stimolo
visivo che ad esempio la vista di queste
slide per evitare questo i neuroni
devono organizzarsi in reti precisa e
complesse ma nonostante questa
precisione i neuroni comunque hanno un
margine di dinamicità un margine di
movimento il cervello quindi non è un
sistema non è un impalcatura stabile è
un continuo divenire appunto quando
siamo bambini
il nostro cervello deve favorire dei
neuroni devono connettersi in queste
precise reti per evitare che si incorra
in asili drammatici e la rusticità
neuronale di un bambino appunto
scolpisce il suo cervello in base alle
esperienze che egli compie alla sua
infanzia e quindi ecco perché si
consiglia che un bambino si sviluppi in
un ambiente ricco di stimoli affinché
sviluppi quelle funzioni che sono
proprie di una crescita sana e corretta
ecco perché è fondamentale che si inizi
ad imparare ad esempio lo studio di non
ama lingua di un nuovo sport oppure lo
studio di come suonare un nuovo
strumento al più presto possibile dato
che in questo momento le connessioni tra
neuroni sono in fase di formazione e
risultano quindi più malleabili
attenzione però ciò può sembrare che io
vi sto dicendo che è impossibile per un
adulto iniziare ad esempio lo studio
lo spagnolo perché magari apparenti
spagnoli no questo è sbagliatissimo la
plasticità neurale si mantiene sempre
attiva anche se con diversi fedeli di
intensità la plasticità quindi rende il
nostro cervello come se fosse un muscolo
un muscolo che deve essere costantemente
allenato costantemente spronato a fare
meglio
ecco quindi l'intelligenza magari si
pensa che alcuni di noi sono abbiano in
dote un intelligenza maggiore di altre
questo è sbagliato infatti
l'intelligenza la reattività sono tutte
facoltà che possono essere allenate noi
possiamo allenarci con la nostra mente
appunto a rispondere in minor tempo ai
problemi che la vita ci pone ogni giorno
e questo favorisce anche l'apprendimento
l'apprendimento come funziona noi
ripetiamo una serie di gesti o di azioni
formiamo quindi sono consolidati e
questi formano un automatismo cioè una
serie di movimenti di cui noi siamo
perfettamente padroni e cosa in viene
invece a livello cellulare
il circuito neuronale corrispondente a
quel gesto quell'azione viene così
potenziato e sarà possibile richiamarlo
più facilmente ecco come l'apprendimento
si collega così alla memoria infatti
ricordando frequentemente un evento si
favorisce la formazione di un ricordo
permanente ecco che l'apprendimento e la
memoria sono connessi dalla plasticità e
d'altronde è impossibile apprendere
qualcosa soprattutto per quanto riguarda
la matematica se prima non lo si è
compreso se prima non lo si è
memorizzato ma dove si trovano i
cosiddetti neuroni della memoria sono in
una particolare zona del cervello
chiamata ippocampo caratteristiche
appunto per la sua forma di un
cavalluccio marino e quindi dal latino
hippocampus i neuroni di questa zona
amplificano e riducono le loro
connessioni in base a quanto vivido è un
ricordo
ecco perché questo è stato proprio
dimostrato da uno studio condotto sui
tassisti di londra
queste persone per ottenere il proprio
lavoro devono svolgere un particolare
test che richiede la conoscenza quasi
perfetta nella planimetria urbana ecco
come si è dimostrato e si è osservato
che nei periodi di preparazione
queste persone mostravano un ippocampo
più ampio della norma di contro lo
stress situazione che tutti
sperimentiamo soprattutto se quello
prolungato e quindi quello che diventa
così cronico comporta alla perdita delle
connessioni tra i neuroni i neuroni così
vedono quindi meno la loro facoltà di
trasmettere il loro impulso alla cellula
successiva e quindi vengono a morire lo
stress cronico porta alla diminuzione
del volume dell'ippocampo e quindi può
scaturire in una condizione patologica
nota come depressione in questo caso
cronica patologia che è trattata sia
stimolando proprio la plasticità e anche
se a livello farmaceutico che a livello
di una terapia psicologica prima vi ho
parlato di allenare la nostra mente
ma in che senso voi vi chiederete come
posso io allenare la mia mente giusta
domanda possiamo benissimo fare
cruciverba possiamo benissimo svolgere
molti sudoku leggere molto ma proprio
riferendoci alla palestra è stato
dimostrato che la corsa non solo effetti
benefici sul nostro sul nostro corpo ma
anche sulla nostra mente la corsa
stimola la plasticità sinaptica e non
solo stimola anche la neurogenesi
neurogenesi che è una una funzione
recentemente scoperta dai
neuroscienziati ossia e lo sviluppo
spontaneo di nuovi neuroni in un
cervello adulto questa facoltà può
essere quindi
quindi sviluppata e può essere
utilizzata per la prevenzione di quelle
malattie terribili che sono ad esempio
l'alzheimer il parkinson a qui potremmo
andare incontro in età adulta in età
avanzata
ecco come possiamo dire che la
plasticità e ciò che collega il nostro
interno quindi il nostro cervello al
mondo circostante grazie alla plasticità
il nostro cervello diventa un muscolo un
muscolo che deve essere sempre allenato
e sempre spronato a fare meglio
dalla mia esperienza ho imparato che non
bisogna mai abbassare la nostra
asticella ma alzarla io ve lo giuro non
mi sarei mai aspettata di essere la
campionessa nazionale delle neuroscienze
non me lo sarei mai aspettato anzi sono
andata lì in quella prova solamente
pensando alla mia preparazione alla mia
passione ossia le studio di questa
materia e ho capito che i fatti
imprevedibili ossia come ad esempio la
vincita di questa competizione possono
avvenire non solo non solo a chi studia
ma chiunque
chiunque solamente spronandosi solamente
con la sola voglia di imparare a fare di
più può migliorare
se da un punto di vista psicologico ma
anche da un punto di vista relazionale e
sociale perché d'altronde un cervello
vivo è un cervello plastico
[Applauso]